bonjour je suis patrick mignola je lui
porte parole du modem pour celles et
ceux qui ne connaissent pas je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver bientôt à
guidel parce qu'on va avoir ce jour là
l'occasion de faire
vraiment de la politique c'est à dire
qu'il y aura des femmes et des hommes
qui sont dans notre courant de pensée et
puis il ya des femmes et des hommes qui
seront pas forcément d'accord avec nous
et imaginez contrairement à ce qu'on
peut voir sur tous les plateaux de télé
en ce moment on va pouvoir débattre en
se respectant en s'écoutant et en
cheminant ensemble on va montrer que
parti politique comme le nôtre assume sa
responsabilité c'est à dire fixer une
vision s'appuyait sur des convictions
mais être capable de réinterroger à tout
moment les solutions qu'ils proposent
alors on vous espère évidemment nombreux
et puis ça me fera très plaisir que vous
veniez moi qui étais président du groupe
des députés à l'assemblée nationale dans
la mandature précédente ne serait ce que
pour saluer ceux qui ont été blessés
électoralement et surtout pour saluer
tous les petits nouveaux qui sont
arrivés à l'assemblée nationale et qui
vraiment ont besoin de votre soutien